am terminat expediția mea în Delta
Dunării de trei zile și fac acest video
ca să fac un rezumat și să trag și niște
concluzii să luăm cu începutul am ajuns
la Tulcea în jurul orei 10:00 la ora 12
an laina 23 acolo m am întâlnit cu
Marian Mincu de la gigant fiam de la el
am învățat
multe de fapt el mi a dat multe sfaturi
pentru pescuitul pe ape
sălbatice tot el m a trimis pe un
canal în jurul milei 23 asta în prima
zi l am întrebat cum e treaba cu
pescuitul dacă se prinde pește și mi a
zis că apa fiind crescută foarte
greu ca să folosesc cuvintele lui este
zăpăcit și cam așa a fost dar totuși am
avut câteva prezentări am mers pe acest
canal timpul pentru pescuit în prima zi
a fost destul de limitat am pescuit
aproximativ două 3 ore am ajuns pe acest
canal dar înainte de a ajunge pe acest
canal a trebuit s o iau pe alte canale
și am zis totuși Hai să sondez și acele
canale să văd dacă există pește pe pe
ele eu sondez cu sonar Lawrence și sondă
live cumva Vezi Cam tot ce mișcă în apă
adică dacă e pește acolo îl vezi 100% am
sondat două canale până să ajung pe
canalul pe care mi l a recomandat Marian
și nu am văzut nici măcar o mișcare nici
măcar un pește am ajuns pe canalul
acesta am stat cam o oră și pe acest
canal să găsesc o codată unde unde ținea
pește Unde era pește Dar de fapt am
găsit două locuri într una am văzut mai
mult pește și într una mai puțin le am
le am salvat pe sonar și m am dus la cea
unde am văzut mai mult pește e
normal am pescuit
cu dumble și cu boil uri rețeta făcută
de mine pe bază de cereale cu semințe cu
semințe în în
ea am prins doi crapi doi sau trei Nici
nu mai știu exact
oricum am m am pus m am pus pe locul de
pescuit am aruncat câteva buis uri Aici
am făcut și o greșeală dar o s o zic la
sfârșit am aruncat câteva buis uri
și am montat lansetele după ce am
aruncat prima lansetă în A nu patru am
prins în prima zi pentru că mi aduc
aminte că am prins trei trei la dumble
și unul la unul la
bois Am avut două lansete puse cu dumble
și două puse cu bois Ok două pe două
lansete am pus cu momitor și pe două
lansete am pus Plumb normal inline asta
a fost prima zi am prins patru ciortani
am pescuit în jur de două tre ore A doua
zi de pescuit am am început o de
dimineață am plecat undeva pe la 6:30 de
la cazare și timp de două ore am sondat
canalul șontea să văd dacă găsesc pește
când am ajuns pe O buclă în canalul shte
am văzut Doi pescari acolo pe unul
dintre ei îl cunoșteam este un pescar
vechi al Deltei Dunării și cumva dacă el
pescuia acolo am zis că trebuie să fie
și pește și m am oprit în locurile
respective am întors barca am băgat
sonda în apă și am început să sond
și am stat în jur de 30 40 de minute pe
locul acela ca să văd dacă există pește
și
am am văzut că peștele stătea cumva Deci
nu stătea pe mijlocul canalului stătea
cumva aproape de stuf și Ieșea din stuf
dar pe jos nu în coloana de apă adică
mergea mergea pe substrat am văzut
chestia asta și mi am căutat un loc unde
să pot să să pot să mă ancorez Cu barca
m am ancorat cu barca Și am stat acolo
până pe la ora două și cred că am prins
în jur de patru sau cinci ciortani am
mai avut o
trăsătură un Run Cum se zice super super
interesant Nu știu dacă era mare foarte
mare dar cert e că a fugit s a dus bine
cu ea și a intrat în stuf și n am reușit
să l scot de acolo dar na Asta e știți
știți vorba aia Cel mai mare pește pe
care l ai prins e ăla care pe care l ai
scăpat așa că na nu știu dimensiunea
Deci am prins cam patru pi Ciortan
acolo și aici am nădit Deci și aici am
dat buil uri am nădit după ce undeva pe
la ora 2:00 se tăi asă trăsăturile parcă
nu mai prindeam a încă ceva Deci eu am
început pescuit î mii aduc aminte că m
am uitat la ceas la ora 10:00 la ora
10:00 și până la ora 2:00 prinsesem
patru Giordani dar am văzut că nu deja
de 40 de minute nicio mișcare nimic și
am zis să schimb locul să merg pe primul
canal pe care am pescuit în prima zi
pentru că îi salvasem locurile și Era
clar că găsesc acolo pește și așa am
făcut Am plecat Am stres Culele și am
plecat am ajuns acolo în jurul orei
3:30
și pe locul unde unde l am pe care l am
îl salvasem pe sonar am văzut foarte
mult pește Deci peștele se mișca era pe
substrat dar rare ori se ridica în
coloana de
apă m am m am ancorat Am dat în J de 2
kg de boil Lis
nadă și după care am băgat lansetele și
aici am prins doar doi
ciortani Cam astea au fost cam astea au
fost zilele de
pescuit apa crescută venea iarbă pe
fir Dacă ți vine iarbă pe fir este un
pescuit dificil pentru că se agață de
fir și trebuie să scoți din apă
deranjezi faci gălăgie Plus că toată apa
toată iarba care se prinde pe fir
vibrează în apă
adică peștele poate să se sperie de
lucrul
acesta Ok acum haide să vă spun
greșelile pe care eu le am
făcut și concluziile pe care le
trag prima greșeală pe care am făcut o A
fost faptul că am
nădit în pescuitul crapului pe ape
private atunci când pescuiesc în malul
de vizavi unde știu că este pește de
regulă nu nădesc acolo niciodată pentru
că n am de ce să nădesc dacă peștele e
deja acolo Știu că l voi prinde același
lucru ar fi trebuit să l fac și pe apă
sălbatică pentru că eu am văzut peștele
pe sonar dacă el era acolo Eu nu mai
trebuia să i dau nadă să i dau o
oportunitate să mănânce mai mult într un
loc trebuia să arunc
doar doar monturile și să aștept să vină
trăsătura pentru că crapul ce
face dacă el are oportunitatea de a
alege o mâncare care este mai puțin
periculoasă o va alege pe aia Adică
faptul că eu am acul ăla acolo cârligul
am cârligul că se zice cârlig Dar bine e
corect șa Din punctul meu de vedere
faptul că eu am cârligul acolo S ar
putea să i trezească suspiciuni și el va
Alege să mănânce boy list urile sau
dumble urile care nu la ele Deci asta
asta a fost asta a fost prima greșeală
nu ar fi trebuit să nădesc Din punctul
meu de vedere sau cel puțin ar fi
trebuit să încerc minim o oră o oră
jumătate fără nad fără să arunc
cantitate de nă a doua greșeală pe care
am făcut o A fost faptul că nu am
încercat un pescuit de
finețe la fel pe ape sălbatice atunci
când peștele este mofturos când se
întâmplă ceva când este un pescuit greu
folosesc monturi de finețe dar de finețe
mă refer la 18 la act de 16 de 18 Da
doar ca să am prezentare să văd că este
peștele acolo să l activez cumva să pot
să prind același lucru ar fi trebuit să
fac și aici Eu am avut prezentări dar le
am avut mai rare probabil că dacă aș fi
avut niște ace de
10 cu niște dumble uri poate mai mici
decât cele pe care le am avut și bois
uri mai mici poate că provoca mai multe
trăsături poate nu știu sigur dar ar
putea avea logică lucrul acesta și eu nu
l am încercat Deci data viitoare o să mă
asigur că am la mine și monturi
fine a treia greșeală pe care am făcut o
A fost că nu am sondat substratul adică
nu am văzut ce Nici măcar n am fost
curios Nici măcar nu mi am adus aminte
de chestia asta vă spun că mi am adus
aminte de lucrul ăsta când am pescuit la
somn și am dat din greșeală cu plumbul
de de pământ plumbul la somn este 250 de
g s a afundat efectiv Nu știu probabil
vreo 20 cm în mâl și când l am tras a
opus rezistență Deci e clar că acolo era
mâl pe zona unde am pescuit eu la somn
și atunci mi a venit ideea și mi am zis
Ok dar uite eu nu am sondat să văd ce
substrat am atunci când am pescuit la
crab pentru că o altă posibilitate ar fi
fost
ca momitorul meu sau plumbul meu am
pescuit cu 80 de g să se fi afundat cu
totul un mâl dacă era un mâl cum îi zice
oin asta a fost a treia greșeală Deci
data viitoare îmi propun să suez
substratul și să găsesc soluții să văd
dacă sau să caut un substrat tare totuși
unde să pescuiesc chiar dacă sunt peștii
acolo Probabil că n o să pot să îi prind
cu o frecvență atât de mare Astea sunt
cele trei greșeli pe care le am făcut
iar acum ca și concluzii e clar că nu
voi mai face greșelile astea și voi
încerc și am învățat din din greșeli ce
mai vreau să zic este că totuși
comportamentul crapului pe
sălbatic pare să fie sau regulile pe
care le fundamentele pe care le am în
pescuitul pe ape
private pare că sunt la fel multe dintre
ele cu pescuitul pe ape sălbatice deși
sunt foarte mulți comentatori pe
internet care au spus că ă
pescuitul pe ape sălbatice este mult
mult mai dificil decât pe ape private și
Au dreptate lucrul acesta Pentru că este
densitate mai mică de pește Dar
fundamentele sunt aceleași Din punctul
meu de vedere poate că nu toate dar
multe dintre ele sunt
aceleași cam asta este concluzia mea în
urma acestei partide de pescuit și în
urma discuțiilor pe care le am avut la
un pahar de de bere
cu localnicii din Delta Dunării
cam atât cam atât de la mine dacă ți a
plăcut acest video te rog frumos să să
dai un like să dai un share să dai un
comentari orice iar dacă ai întrebări nu
ezita să mi le pui și te ajut cu mare
drag Te salut și îți doresc fir întins